- One of your daughters
likes to sing as well, right?
I saw a video of singing,
she was singing Ben Platt.
- To Ben Platt, yes.
Well he was brought, my
birthday party this year,
he was brought over
as a human (laughs)
birthday present because
- Nice.
- No one knows what to get me,
and this year
- Human birthday present.
- My friends got me human presents.
One of my friends brought
Lin-Manuel Miranda,
and my husband had emailed
Ben Platt and said,
"Would you come over?" And she sat down
and locked the bedroom door
and sang him one of his songs.
- [Ben Platt] That is so good.
- [Kristen] Oh my God,
look how happy he is.
- [Kristen's Daughter Singing]
♪ I'll always be there
- [Ne-Yo] Wow!
- He was actually recently on this show.
He is the nicest human.
- He's the best.
- And he's so talented.
We got to sing together.
He's incredibly talented.
- He's incredible, yes.
I'm a big fan and so
are my daughters, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, so
- She commandeered him.
(Ne-Yo laughs)
- [Kelly] She locked the
door, he's mine! (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.